[Music]
Hey everybody, I'm Paul. I'm the founder
of Browserbase and I am obsessed with
browsers. Specifically, one type of
browsers, headless browsers. And I'm
here to talk about how the browser is
all you need. It's not attention. It's
not MCP, it's the browser or
specifically the browser MCP server is
all you need. And I'm going to try and
keep it light on slides. We only have a
hundred to get through in 20 minutes,
but you and I, we can do it together.
Uh, just stay with me for 20 more
minutes. Okay, so first of all, a little
about browser base. This is what it
looks like to build your own browser
infrastructure. It's messy and it breaks
all the time. With browser base, we can
let you run thousands of headless
browsers in the cloud. Very easy to
control. And you might be wondering
like, well, why do I need a browser?
Well, every AI agent needs a web
browser. That's the point of this whole
talk. So, of course, you know, I can
talk to you about how to scale browser
infrastructure and all that interesting
stuff, but that's too pluggy. We'll save
that for later. But I do know quite a
bit about, you know, how customers are
using browsers as part of their AI agent
applications. Specifically with MCP, we
have the most popular browser automation
MCP server out there. And the reason why
people choose browserbased to run their
headless browser MCP is that we make it
really nice and and really can help you
scale your infrastructure. And when you
think about why do I need a browser?
Well, I like to think about two things.
You have AI agents and the legacy
internet. You know, the DMV is not going
to have an MCP server anytime soon. My
barber shop is not going to open a
GraphQL API for me to schedule a
haircut. As much as I keep begging John
to do it, uh, he's got better things to
do. So, if we want AI agents to interact
with the rest of the legacy internet,
they need a bridge. And I really do
believe that the browser is that bridge
between AI and the rest of the internet.
And this is the unsexy internet, I might
add. It's it's the internet that's not
going to get a lot of attention. I've
seen countless flight bookers and
countless restaurant pickers. And I have
not seen anyone do the thing I need,
which is a Delaware franchise tax filing
agent. Any founders in the room have
done that before? Not super fun. And I
think people use a lot of acronyms these
days. you know, you have MCP, you have
ADA, you open API, but if those aren't
available, you can just do what could be
considered the the dumb thing. You can
just use the website. And websites are
out there. There are plenty of them.
There are billions of websites. And when
your user is going to prompt your agent
to do something, you might not always
have a firstparty integration available.
That's where a browser is kind of the
integration of last resort, the path
that you can take your agent down if you
don't have something, a primary
integration already built in. And you
might be wondering, well, okay, Paul,
cool. I get it. You're beating this
thing dead. AI agency in the browser,
but how do they control it? Well, you
can think about web agents and browser
tools. First of all, you know, what is a
web agent? I want to keep this technical
as this is a bunch of AI architects,
right? You know, web agents, we've we've
heard about them for a long time. Take a
model and then have it generate some
code to control a browser by generally
parsing the DOM on the page, the HTML
and the CSS. Web Voyager was early here.
Adept did a lot of really cool stuff
here with their Fuji models. Opening had
operator proxy by convergence. now
Salesforce H company everyone was kind
of doing a lot of this stuff last year
and we really got to see a lot of web
agents in production uh but they were
still early days you know and web
voyager was first you know it was taking
screenshots of a page it was using chain
of thought prompting and then from that
it was saying click the button at this
coordinate uh sometimes they were doing
these things we'll talk about a second
called um labeling on top of the page
but I think it's pretty cool because we
haven't changed that much from this
there's really are two different types
of web agents there's vision driven
agents these are ones that predominately
screenshots as context for the model.
They might do some marking up of the
screenshot to indicate what box to click
on. Um, or there's textbased web agents
who predominately use HTML as a context
of the model. Um, both have different
approaches, pros and cons. Text web
agents use X paths and playright code.
Some may argue it's more repeatable.
Vision models can be more accurate on
more complex pages. Uh, there's
trade-offs here and there there, you
know, it really does depend on what
website you're trying to automate.
Here's an example on a vision agent
using set of marks prompting. You can
see these little boxes here where you're
marking up what you should click and the
agent will or the model will turn and
say click the box labeled 25. That's
going to help you out. And on the
DOMbased agent side, there's also ideas
of like taking HTML and how can we
transform HTML to make it more reliable
for web agents. So the accessibility
tree is something that's built in every
page uh in a lot of applications where
you can take a different structure of
the same information and condense it
down where you get the same layout but
without all the extra div tags and
classes. So we have vision based agents
and DOM based agents and there's now
also computer models which are kind of
like the next step here where well let's
train a whole model on this stuff.
Previously we're just using like the
stock image models but now we can train
that model on these things called web
trajectories. And I won't go too much
into this. There's a lot of great papers
out here. I'd recommend this paper
linked down here about like web
trajectories and how you can generate
them to do URL to teach models, how to
not just pick the right button on the
page, but how to reason across multiple
pages about the right path to take. But
all in all, there's just a lot of
innovation here happening on teaching AI
how to browse the web. And this stuff is
getting good. It is working and you can
use it today to help add some sort of
extra functionality to your applications
if you're making the right choices. And
I I will kind of add you kind of want to
think about if you want a web agent or a
browser tool. And you may have never
heard of like what the difference is
here, but there is a difference in my
head. Like a web agent is kind of like
one prompt to many actions. I think
opening as operator is a good example of
this. You say, "Hey operator, go, you
know, file my Delaware franchise tax."
You give it some some prompt, it's going
to go take many actions. And if you give
it that same prompt twice, it might take
two different paths to get the task
done. Web agents are good. They're like
little cockroaches. you just they're
just going to keep trying to find a way
to complete your task. Um, but they're a
little bit more non-deterministic
because the reasoning is in their
control. Whereas like browser tools are
like one action or one prompt. You say
click the sign-in button, that thing's
going to click the sign-in button. You
ask it to purchase the Amazon item you
want. That's a series of multiple steps
that really might be more suited for a
web agent. So, we have a framework
called stage hand that we think is the
best browser tool. Um, and it really
does depend on what you want. If you
know what your workflow is going to be
with some highlevel steps, you can
actually use a browser tool to take
those steps and translate them into
reliable web actions. If you don't know
what you're going to do, if if you don't
know what the prompt will be, a web
agent more generically might be the
right fit. But I do believe your AI
agent needs a browser tool. Another
thing I'll add is like you may want to
think about with MCP, what types of
servers are you integrating? So a
vertical MCP server with something like
linear where it's going to give you
options to control specific things on a
specific task like create a linear
ticket create assign someone to the
linear ticket whereas like a horizontal
MCP server you're going to have some
sort of primitive that can do many
things you know for browsing we view it
as a horizontal MCB server you're
exposing prims like click a button on a
page now that page may change there may
be many different pages but when you
have a horizontal MCB server with one
server you have the opportunity to
automate the whole web and these like
you know you will see vertical MTV
servers which are more direct tool calls
as like an important part of your agent.
I'm not saying we replace those with
browsers. If you are interacting with
Salesforce, you probably should just use
a Salesforce MCP. You don't need a
browser there. But if you're interacting
with custom bespoke MCP built by large
enterprise that doesn't sorry a custom
bespoke CRM built by a large enterprise
that doesn't have an MCP server, you
don't have to go reverse engineer APIs.
You can use a browser tool and a browser
MCP server to go out and automate that.
Is that making sense for everybody so
far? Okay, thank you guys. Hearing some
heads nodding. Okay, a few other notes
on like MCP and all these like concerns
I have here. Um I I do think that MCPs
are going to have to pass compliance and
dynamic tool discovery. This idea that
you can plug in your agent to an
infinite toolbox of MCP servers is going
to be hard for CISOs to get on board
with, right? you're going to want to be
able to select which MCB servers make
the most sense. And with a browser or a
horizontal MCB server, this could be
browser, it could be email, could be
anything. Uh you really only have to
onboard one MCB server as opposed to an
MCB server for each individual
integration. Secondly, like yeah, that's
the most important way. Secondly, like
eval most most benchmarks are fake news.
Just want to let you know, especially
when the company putting out the
benchmark is the one that's also ranking
themselves. So I would be very uh
critical of public benchmarks of any web
agent you see out there or any model you
see out there. You really need your own
evals. My friend Anker who runs brain
trust he supports our evals. I really
like them because then we're able to say
hey actually for our web agent we're
building which models are the best model
for this web task or for this certain
website and you can get really
intelligent and honest about what you
actually need to do to automate the web
and which model is the right choice for
you. Finally, I think you need
observability. If your AI agent is
controlling a browser, you need to be
able to see what happens in the browser.
Browse base bundles this out of the box
though. You can build your own. You
know, taking screenshots, recording
history, recording actions, making sure
that you know exactly where your agent
went to and why is important because
let's say your agent is going to go buy
an Xbox and it buys you AirPods. You
want to understand what prompts went
into that, what page paths it took, and
really break that down. At browser base,
we include this in every browser is
sessions are recorded, logs are
available. It really makes it quite
easy. Okay, so that was like a lot on
browsers. I got a ton of time left, but
I'll end with this one point. The
browser is the default MCP server for
the rest of the internet. If you need to
integrate with something, whether that's
with MCP, an API, and there's not
something available, you should really
consider including a browser because a
browser is all you need. And since I'm
doing so well on time, I'm going to do
some live coding because I feel like
there hasn't been enough live coding in
this room today. So, I'm breaking it
out. And let's pull up cursor and bring
it over here. And it's going to be so
hard to see, but let me try.
Give me this. Please
love. All right. So, we have cursor
right here in all of my screenshots. I'm
a screenshot hoarder. I apologize. So, I
pulled up the cursor MCP server. uh
sorry the cursor controller and I've
written a prompt. It says create a new
browser session. Navigate to sfpca.org.
Close out any modals and find a dog for
adoption in San Francisco. Return the
URL. We'll click enter. And I may have
to jump to a browser here really
quickly. So you can see it's calling the
browser session tool. It's generated a
browser session right here. And you can
look how it's actually making these
individual tool calls on the page. If I
pull up the session at the same time and
scoot this tab over there,
we can see in parallel the browser is
loading and as our MCP server is making
these tool calls. Right now it's trying
to close out the modal. It's navigating
the website and thinking about how like
there's a reasoning model here that's
deciding what should I do? What should I
call? Uh these tools are exposed and now
we go here. We have been given a dog
with this URL and one of you will be
going home with a lucky dog today. All
right, can I get a drum roll, please?
All right, that was so half-hearted, but
thank you. Uh, give me a dog. Yay, there
we go. Oh, they really want that 200k
match. Uh, this campaign's been running
for a while. I feel kind of bad for you.
Uh, but that's a good example of what
will happen when you're building these
web automations. Sometimes modals will
pop up. Sometimes things you aren't
expecting may happen on the web page.
You need to have an AI agent driving the
page with primitives so it can react to
any sort of weird changes that happen.
And hopefully you can integrate with
things that aren't going to be AI
native. To me, the most important
problems to solve in AI right now are
the unimportant boring problems. And
they're going to require, you know,
intelligent, you know, engineering to
both bring the best models to the unsexy
problems. And when we talk to customers
of browserbased, they're not just
Perplexity or Clay or uh Commir. They're
also a 55-year-old dairy trucking
company who has never hired an engineer
in their 55 years until this year. And
the first thing they did was use browser
base to automate a really painful ops
workflow. So, if I can somehow pull my
slides back, I don't know if I'll be
able to. I might just have to move this
bad boy over here. We'll just go for it
live. Uh yeah, screw it. We'll just do
this. Okay, so if you do want to try a
browser MCP server, it's available
today. You can actually go ahead and
scan this QR code and sign up or use
this to try adding some sort of
automation. It's really easy. If I can
use it, you can use it. I promise. I'm
going to pause. I'm seeing some photos
being taken. Amazing. Great. And and
finally, you know, if you are looking to
uh join a company that's growing
quickly, browse's been around for a year
and a half. We're 30 people. We're
backed by some really great investors
and we would love for you to come build
the future of automation with us. All
right, that's all my time. I might have
a minute for some questions or two if
that's okay. Yeah, if there's any
questions, happy to to take them.
Otherwise, uh thanks so much everybody.
Any questions?
Hold on. Maybe do hands if that's okay.
Uh we'll go uh front and then back.
Yeah, go ahead.
Do you use specific model for
navigation? Like it's your own model or
uh like a
when the browser is scrolled and so on
and so on or you utilize different we
are model agnostic so browser brace is
just the infrastructure for running
headless browsers as well as the
frameworks and tools we have an MCP
server we have a framework called stage
hand which is like playright but better
um you bring your own model and you may
want to choose different models based on
your conditions if you are doing HIPPA
and you need like zero data retention
and open AI you might want to use one of
their models so you bring the model we
bring the infra
I'm sorry I'm just go ahead say it
You could just we just skip it. Yeah,
the example we just did I used uh yeah
the cursor agent mode I think it's 40
max or sorry claw it's probably 40
sonnet right now is what I have baked in
there. Go ahead. Love the questions.
Keep them coming. How do you guys manage
uh anything that requires human in the
loop? Because we have to deal with lot
of legacy infrastructure but it's
financial data. So an adviser wants to
review it before it goes into a
financial planning tool something like
that. How do you bring in some sort of
human in the loop interaction over to a
browser? A and B if um because this is
financial data, we also want to uh give
users a clear view of what the agent has
done. Is there a way we can send that
information even if they couldn't
interfere in the process? Yeah, I I was
just going to hop over the slide. So,
not only do we have recordings available
and they can be turned on or off
depending on data sensitivity, you can
embed these recordings into a userfacing
application and show your user what
happened, we also have this feature
called the live view where you can embed
an iframe and show exactly what's
happening in the browser. And better
yet, if someone wants to a human wants
to come in and click and type in on the
live view, they can do that as well. So,
it's not just for browser automation, it
could be a browser co-pilot and it's an
iframe, so it's a browser inside a
browser, which is kind of fun to see.
Yeah. Thank you. I think there's a
question over here. Yeah. Then we'll go
to you guys next. So my question is kind
of two parts. One, have you dealt with
captures at all? And is there and do you
see like future websites kind of using
similar strategies to defend against
like automation tools that only users
can use their website? Yeah. Captions.
So for the longest time there's never
been like good bots on the internet and
captures were built to stop all bots.
But now there are good bots and bad
bots. And at browserbase, we do offer
capture solving in proxies. It's
something that's needed to browse the
web. We have customers that use capture
solving against their own captures
because they can't get their sec ops
team to like get through a good way to
bypass that. However, I think longer
term, you know, my friend Michael work
was just talking about captures. Agent
authentication is the path to avoid
captures. Most captures we see at
browser base are when someone's logging
in. Once you log in, you know who the
agent is. You know who they're acting on
behalf of. And I'm really hopeful that
solving captures the browsers is a
short-term solution as we figure out how
to do agent authentication on the
internet longer term. But down to talk
about that afterwards. Come find me. I
got I got a minute 42 seconds. I'm gonna
I'm holding us to it. Yeah. So during
web navigation like I think my question
was related to captures, but during web
navigation if does the browser actually
detect it's a robot that's doing the
navigation and does it increase capture
coming up? Yeah, I I think that the way
that capture detection works is often
based on your behavior. And what we
advise our customers is like listen, you
know, even though we provide the best
stealth browsing features necessary in
the end, if you're a bad citizen of the
internet, you are going to get blocked.
It's an inevitability. You can see this
on LinkedIn. If you have an agent that's
using LinkedIn, LinkedIn measures how
many actions you take for a minute. And
if you're violating that, you know,
you're going to get stopped. So, we
advise our customers is like, you need
to be a good citizen of the internet
first. You need to try and obey
robots.ext. You need to be careful what
you're doing. And if not, like you're
going to have a really hard time. And no
matter what we do at browsers, we can't
stop that. We can help with the simple
things, but if you're doing something
that's against the law, unethical, we
don't really want that on our platform.
[Music]